for me if you're not positive to society
guess what go have five kids
go have six kids go as many kids as
possible I'm trying to get people of the
right values and principles who are net
positive to society to have more kids
and I think we need to do that because I
think
the right people are a little too
conservative when it comes down to
having kids
so safe so when you have those kids
you're a successful guy yeah
um that's you're not saying that the
right people are only successful people
but I imagine that's not money driven
it's not money no ethics principles
driven now you happen to be very wealthy
how do you make sure your kids avoid the
Trap of being spoiled brats that are no
of no benefit to society and they are
lazy because they've just been
you know gifted a fortune it's a great
question